[Music]
you
IBM Business Process manager version 857
introduces a new portal that supports
phone tablet and desktop browsers here
the portal is shown on an iPhone 6 plus
the work dashboard displays a list of
tasks that the current user can claim
and work on pressing the 3 bar icon
reveals a sidebar that contains the
current users profile a list of
dashboards and saved searches and a list
of launcher role processes and services
pressing the options icon reveals a
sidebar that contains a list of
processes the user is following mentions
that have been made by other BPM users
in the web links that have been
configured by an administrator
nina is on an airplane waiting for gate
departure she can do some work on her
phone she needs to open an onboarding
task for jane dean a new hire in cloud
analytics sales nina opens the left
sidebar and starts an instance of the
new sales position onboarding process
she can use the quick search feature to
easily find a new task in the task list
she opens the task claims it types Jane
Dean's name
looks next and submits the request when
she returns to the work list the search
filter is still active and she sees that
the task is no longer there as expected
because it's complete
so she clears the filter and the
remaining available tasks are now shown
back in the office nina creates a saved
search that her team can use to track
failed lead tasks she clicks create safe
search she leaves the claimed and
available criterion in place and adds
another search start or closed the now
tasks that have the word start or
closing them are shown in the task list
she also adds assigned to team and types
in the name of her team she adds some
useful columns as well assigned to team
and to business data columns lead amount
and lead viability she gives the search
the name start and close sales and she
shares it with her team sales
consultants
nina would like to see this saved serfs
when she logs in she does this by
clicking the show details icon next to
the save search name and clicks the star
this brings the saved search above the
show less separator she drags a saved
search above work and now after she logs
back in the start and closed sales saved
search is her landing page
portal is highly configurable this is
the portal after changes were made to
the BPM theme theme changes are easy to
make note that changes to the theme
apply to all BPM users theme changes are
not saved on a per user basis
look for more videos in the future
covering many aspects of BPM version 85
7 these will include external activities
responsive coaches case process
tutorials and more thanks for watching
[Music]